il y a 20 ans les Français découvraient
Loana Loana a 23 ans depuis 5 ans elle
est gogo dancer alors qu'elle remporte
la première édition de Love Story sur M6
la jeune blonde de 24 ans pourtant
inconnue auparavant va très vite faire
la une de tous les médias Loana a sorti
son superbe corps de la voiture une
autorité fulgurante qui va rapidement
mener la star dans une véritable
descente aux enfers
et les dépressions successives là non
parfois à faire le pire et puis
peut-être augmenter exprès mais que j'en
suis sorti indemois de se reprendre en
main ses relations et son rapport à la
drogue vont souvent faire replonger la
jeune femme dans ses phases les plus
sombres elle était dans un état très
grave mais elle peut encore elle peut
encore parler et elle va être transférée
en hôpital psychiatrique après plusieurs
mois d'absence aujourd'hui loana est de
retour sur le devant de la scène sa vie
ses projets sa reconstruction elle nous
dira tout ce soir sans tabou dans TPMP
people
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
excusez-nous pardon juste avant
il est bienveillant
voilà
mais tu as paru une vision en tout cas
tu es très belle voilà ça c'est bien
voilà mais la prochaine fois
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
[Rires]
j'en ai perdu ma fiche
on revient à toi toutes les questions
j'ai l'impression que tu veux déjà
beaucoup mieux ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle c'est ainsi que tu es très
belle
lol on va en parler alors tu as lancé il
y a pas longtemps c'est vrai qu'en
revanche financièrement c'est plus
compliqué tu vis du RSA c'est vrai ça
c'est quoi le reste ça c'est 400 € par
mois 530 € par mois ou tu vis en fait tu
partages un peu ta ta ta maison entre
entre ta maman et
Eric prayer ton meilleur ami donc de la
France c'est ça
on va être honnête c'est un petit peu ça
quoi c'est pas vulgaire
il y a mon toutou qui m'attend
après le loft qui était très beau
prédateurs
personne ne me croit même ma famille et
mes amis ne m'ont pas cru ma maman comme
on vit beaucoup ensemble et qu'on est
beaucoup plus proche le remarque
maintenant il est vrai que dès qu'il y a
des souplesse sur mon compte ils sont
souvent en soufflets enfin moi j'ai
passé à souffler par exemple
[Musique]
parce que
il est où cet argent justement
de voiture j'ai pas de maison j'ai pas
de la barbe j'ai pas de c'est bizarre
quand même avec tous cet argent c'est ma
question mon chou oui il est parti
améliorer tout est parti tout est parti
et bah de la banque
l'argent partait seul donc déjà
on copier mes cartes bancaires j'ai
changé quatre fois de banque mais des
petits copains ou ta maman je veux pas
dire j'accuse personne
je suis je suis je suis justement donc
j'ai pas utilisé mon agent ci bien sûr
parce que ça fait quand même assez
longtemps que je l'ai vendu je l'ai
vendu en
je sais que vous êtes réconcier avec ta
maman mais si par hasard tu découvrais
que cette enquête que l'argent qui a été
tiré c'était souvent ta maman tu lui en
voudrais beaucoup mais comment tu
pourrais
quand
même
manger que des pâtes donc franchement
ils m'ont révolait cet
argents j'en sais rien ma mère l'a vu
une fois j'ai travaillé j'ai 1000 euros
sur mon compte cinq jours plus tard il
reste 70 c'est fou ça et le là
en procès mais
pour parler avec les banques parce que
ils comprennent pas parce que pour eux
c'est des cartes il y a le code mais il
y a des il y a eu des retraits au
Luxembourg Los Angeles Miami c'est
incroyable alors que j'étais à Paris
donc je regardais mon compte et mes
sources
et qui t'ont volé de l'argent partout
un carton j'adore il y avait la Halle
aux vêtements où tu vendais tes
vêtements les photos tout ça tu as gagné
beaucoup d'argent avant qu'est-ce que tu
en as fait
j'ai eu beaucoup d'argent donc
l'appartement que j'ai acheté c'était il
était il était insulte
d'accord
de choses donc j'ai mis l'argent de
comme je t'aime j'ai mis l'argent de mon
livre et j'ai mis pas mal d'argent de
mes boulots au lieu de partir en
vacances et de m'acheter des fringues de
luxe alors avant d'avoir des questions
les chroniqueurs et oublie pas quelque
chose ici il y a zéro jugement on n'a
aucun on a tous ici on a tous ici j'ai
pas fait que des belles choses parce que
si on est là pour
mentir bien sûr que j'ai pas tout mis
dans mon appartement
ils peuvent se refaire les murs tu vois
alors
juste à côté tu nous as pas vu
j'ai une question
donc voilà
j'ai une question à te poser l'autre
jour notre ami Jordan qui était
interviewé tu as posé une question et ta
réponse ma sidéré il t'a dit la
télé-réalité c'est quoi pour toi et tu
lui aurait perdu mon plus beau souvenir
mon plus beau souvenir mais
est-ce que la téléréalité pour moi enfin
pardon c'est pas le début de l'enfer
pourquoi
c'est justement quand je sors du loft et
quand je remonte on va dire c'est la
grande armée moi j'ai on m'a demandé
qu'est-ce que c'est cette photo-là
représente quoi pour toi ma réponse a
été ça le premier jour de ma nouvelle
vie mais oui mais cette nouvelle ville
Wana c'est une vie qui va t'amener à la
drogue aux élections à des prises de
poids à l'enfer à des dépressions au RSA
tu vois trop mal tu vois trop mal on
voit de nuit tout ça ça aurait pu
m'arriver aussi tu crois bah oui bien
sûr
un défi de Jean-Paul Gaultier sans
couverture de magazine
je vous promets les rencontres et les
rencontres que
j'ai faim
je sais pas qui mais je m'en fiche je
veux dire on quand on meurt en noir fait
avec des billets
qui sont dans la tête qui sont
importants
on t'adore tout le temps et je te
connais depuis que tu étais comme ça
c'est une fin de la télé
à plus de Brigitte Bardot parce que
c'est vrai que tu es né à la télé à la
télévision tu es allé à Saint-Tropez
tout le monde te connaît il y a eu un
moment difficile dans ta vie tu en as
parlé c'était tenté de suicide dieu
merci et non pas été réussi
ce genre de choses là ou pas rien je
peux te dire voilà ça fait 10 ans j'ai
arrêté la drogue l'alcool
que j'entends ce soir tu vois c'est très
bien
que j'ai un doigt en l'air machin comme
ça une photo on dit elle est défoncer je
vais te dire pourquoi
parce que regarde quand on regarde ton
Instagram on a vu un pas longtemps on se
dit il y a il y a est-ce qu'on peut
avoir un Instagram ou tu annonçais que
tu pouvais faire des vidéos et tout ça
si on peut le voir s'il vous plaît voilà
Lolo on se dit pas que c'est une fille
qui est sorti de tout là quand même
regarde mais je sors de l'eau s'il te
plaît pas à moi je sais je sais bah
écoute hein tu arrives de faire des
conneries tu peux des conneries écoute
j'en ai eu marre parce que les gens
critiquent tout le temps allez comme ça
elle est comme ça ben voilà me dis pas
que tu es dans un état là tu es pas
nickel c'est le discours il est 9h du
matin mais c'est pas le problème
[Rires]
là là tu es pas c'est tu vois quand on
voit ça on peut pas se dire
mois d'août Loana là on a pas mis le son
comme ça sur la vie de ma mère et je te
crois mais ça aide pas pour toi ces
vidéos ce que regarde tu vois
un petit peu et tout ça on dit pas les
fraîches mon meilleur ami m'a dit
enlève-la pourquoi au moins on voit que
voilà au naturel il me dit ouais mais au
naturel c'est pas top
mais là c'est vrai l'oeil un peu comme
ça tu parles un peu comme ça et tout
forcément on se dit comme tu es fragile
on dirait de tomber dans ses démons
ouais enfin bon voilà une vidéo et tout
le reste que je mets et tu mesures que
là il y avait pas de démon non il y
avait rien je te crois vers du matin
c'est normal
c'est le premier jour de sa nouvelle
vidéo tout à l'heure le meilleur
souvenirs la nuit du loft et le
lendemain dans l'hôtel machin Porte
Maillot là et c'était effectivement tous
les canards étaient là mais les canards
sérieux le monde Le Figaro les
télérammes à tous tous Paris Match tous
et donc c'est normal qu'elle ait vécu
mais c'est exactement là où tu voulais
être et tu y étais et donc c'était
extraordinaire en revanche là quand tu
pars après la question sur les
effectivement les addictions non mais je
voulais revenir sur ce point-là parce
qu'on ne mesure pas ce que ça représente
c'est logique en revanche est-ce que
honnêtement les
ressemblait être que le 1 c'est pas là
où je voulais être
tu veux remonter sur des podiums mais
aujourd'hui tu pourrais tu crois j'ai
pas dit que je voulais je dis non
pourquoi pas Florian je veux revenir sur
ce que tu disais tout à l'heure quand on
parlait de ton appartement etc parce que
moi j'étais une interviewé plusieurs
fois ces dernières années pour closer et
notamment à l'époque où tu as eu un ex
qu'on va pas nommer que tu as accusé de
violence que tu as aussi dit que il
t'avait peut-être pris un peu d'argent
que tu l'avais aidé pour des achats
personnels etc est-ce que tu penses pas
qu'aujourd'hui l'heure est venu de bien
t'entourer que ce soit médicalement mais
aussi en amour encore une très belle
femme pourquoi tu es encore célibataire
pourquoi il y a personne avec toi pour
te connaître bref j'étais amoureuse oui
j'avais pas mal d'argent oui je lui ai
acheté la qui rêvé oui j'ai acheté une
voiture oui
et en échange il me donnait de l'amour
c'était faux vrai j'en sais rien mais
j'étais amoureuse elle veut pas me
reprocher d'avoir été amoureuse et
d'avoir voulu gâter l'homme de ma vie
moi l'OM à chaque fois je te défends bec
et sur cette émission et j'ai entendu
dire qu'il y avait un projet peut-être
de biopic sur ta vie en pour parler avec
peut-être avec ça la roche-joubert ou
quelqu'un d'autre est-ce que c'est vrai
et si c'est vrai c'est vrai que tu
aimerais incarner ton propre rôle à
l'intérieur
alors
[Musique]
je ne Fouine
je vais te répondre que sur ce sujet là
si on répond oui ou non on est interdit
de en parler ah oui tu aimerais bien le
faire en tout cas voilà ok mais oui bien
sûr
en principe
bien sûr un film de ma vie mais genre
puisque fière alors moi je voulais
d'abord vous dire que je compatis
profondément à tout ce que vous avez
traversé et franchement c'est
visiblement extrêmement dur et j'ai
presque envie de vous dire là maintenant
il faut Fauser il faut vous refaire quoi
il faut vraiment remonter à cheval faire
quelque chose de construit quelque chose
de solide qui qui vous donne une
structure etc etc parce que la question
que j'allais vous poser c'est
vous quand vous retournez sur scène avec
Eryl Prayer
d'accord mais il paraît que c'est pas
très réussi etc et on demande
une date ou quoi soit c'est des
programmés soit soit c'est un petit
scandale derrière soit on dit que c'est
enfin on a l'impression qu'à chaque fois
et là je te dis que le cœur à chaque
fois que tu lances un projet derrière il
y a
on va dire je suis un peu maudite
chercher des dernières années mais c'est
pas ma faute
je veux dire oui il y a des projets
à la dernière minute c'est pas moi qui
le veut je mange j'adore mais c'est vrai
que j'avoue que j'ai pas de chance
[Musique]
on était un petit peu fâché avec Loana
parce que j'avais parlé de sa dentition
et que c'était pour te protéger toi
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'elle faisait
une vidéo les dents bouger et tout le
monde disait qu'elle était défoncé et
moi j'ai pris sa défense parce que je
sais je sais qu'elle le prend défoncer
je sais qu'elle prend plus de drogues et
moi c'était pour te défendre en disant
qu'effectivement c'était pas lié à la
drogue le fait que tu as la dentition
qui bouge après moi j'avais une petite
question pour Loana c'était est-ce que
tu regrettes pas honnêtement on a
travaillé ensemble je te connais je sais
comment tuer je sais que tu es une super
nana tu es très gentille tu as vraiment
un cœur énorme mais ce que je voudrais
savoir c'est est-ce que tu ben justement
pour te défendre parce qu'il y avait
plein de vidéos qui circulent ou tu
avais les dents qui bougeaient et on se
disait que tu n'as pas pu retourner à
Dubaï la deuxième fois c'était un
appareil au départ pour remettre les
vrais dents c'est vrai ou pas ça on m'a
proposé d'y aller la première fois pour
effectuer effectivement
je t'assure que si j'en aurai payé le
deuxième aller-retour gratuit dans
lequel où j'étais j'aurais été bien
comme de pas y être allé donc tu as pas
pu le deuxième maintenant c'est parce
qu'en fait mon chirurgien de dentiste
travailler
à Cagnes-sur-Mer où j'habite et il
travaille le reste du temps à Dubaï donc
en fait il m'a dit si tu viens Dubaï
qu'on te paye tout voilà tu fais un peu
de publicité pour la clinique et le
reste du travail a été fait chez moi
on m'a pas proposé de retourner une
deuxième fois et j'ai pas
refusé parce que j'étais ta question
parce qu'après
est-ce que tu regrettes pas de temps en
temps de poster des vidéos de tes pas
aux meilleurs de ta forme et tu sais
qu'elles vont être reprises dans la
presse on va dire qu'il y a des Français
est-ce que tu veux pas te protéger un
peu des réseaux sociaux et mettre
quelque chose de Clean de propre rien
que pour ta carrière et pour la suite et
vous mettre bon alors
il y a toujours un truc à retenir
la vidéo qui arrive au bout de trois
mois en général tu es pas obligé de ta
forme
Natacha et Benoît moi j'ai une grande
tendresse pour vous le Anna j'ai grandi
avec vous j'étais abonné j'avais la
chaîne et tout je me regardais le loft
c'était toute ma vie c'est toutes ces
semis vingt ans et la tendresse que j'ai
pour vous malheureusement à chaque fois
je me dis mais c'est pas possible est-ce
que vous ne pensez pas que cet univers
Entertainment de télé de divertissement
de réseaux sociaux ça vous brûle à
chaque fois que que vous êtes sous les
feux de projecteurs et que vous brûlez
les ailes vous avez jamais pensé à
changer de vie à devenir un peu madame
tout le monde avoir
été la caméra surtout le temps peut-être
de de guérir parce qu'on sait que vous
étiez aussi un petit peu addict aux
médicaments récemment ça vous a plu
est-ce que tu pourrais tout arrêter tout
arrêter
ça le problème ou pas
non parce que je il y a pas que il y a
pas que j'ai mauvais j'aime les gens qui
me suivent depuis des années j'aime les
commentaires qui me blessent j'aime les
encouragements qu'on me dit j'aime
j'aime faire des photos avec les gens et
leur donner le sourire j'aime des
petites filles qui viennent me dire je
veux juste un câlin de toi parce que tu
ressembles à Barbie bien sûr non mais
est-ce que juste
voilà je voulais savoir si parce que on
a l'impression on veut vous aider mais
que vous obstinez dans une voie qui est
un peu sans issue de la chanson alors
que je pense que si vous deviez être une
star chanson vous le sauriez déjà mais
est-ce qu'il y a pas est-ce que vous
avez un autre talent qui vous
permettrait de rebondir de vous appuyer
dessus un autre métier vous pourriez
faire comment
interview t'avais dit aujourd'hui il y a
plus d'émission de divertissement et de
chansons du coup je peux plus me montrer
mais c'est vrai que ce qu'il voulait
dire c'est quoi ton vrai métier
aujourd'hui du coup maintenant tu sais
quand tu regardes je tape sur Google
c'est marqué ici
je te jure parce que j'ai fait une liste
écrivains chanteuses j'ai plein de
métiers mais chanteuse je sais très bien
que c'est pas mon
question de Magali puis après j'ai un
truc pour toi retourne à Laurence
et oui il crée des vêtements
j'ai une question Loana vos anciens
camarades de love story ils sont assez
désagréables quand ils parlent de vous
ils vous dénigre pas mal je trouve et
voilà ils vous ont lâché totalement et
ils disent limite pour certains non mais
nous on veut pas ça y est on a tout
enfin limite c'est honteux pour eux j'ai
enfin moi je le ressens comme ça ça vous
fait quoi de voir ce cet humiliant quand
même vous voyez ce que je veux dire
non j'en ai rien à faire ça me touche à
l'intérieur
j'aimerais qu'on te montre une photo je
vais te faire du lait à la main quelle
époque voilà hommage hommage hommage à
France 2 mais je trouve ça formidable
est-ce qu'on peut montrer une photo
quand tu revois cette photo là est-ce
que tu as envie de dire à cette jeune
fille a dit à 20 ans à peu près Loana
aujourd'hui fais plus attention et ben
c'est ce que je te dis aussi aujourd'hui
fais attention à ton entourage porte-toi
bien à vous aussi bon samedi mais